كان أحد الأمثلة التي كانت حاسمة
من حيث توجيهي نحو الإسلام من خلال
العديد من التوقفات على طول الطريق هو كيف كنت
في حفلة يموت والد لأنه كان
مشروع إسكان ماونت بليزانت في نيو
بريطانيا كونيتيكت وماونت بليزانت
نسميه مدينة التألق ولكن  لن أخوض في
ذلك ، لكن عندما أغادر ، كان حوالي
منتصف الليل وهذا هو شتاء كونيتيكت الذي يسبق الاحتباس الحراري ،
لذا كان الجو باردًا
وهذه الفتاة البورتوريكية الصغيرة
كان المشروع من أصل أفريقي
بورتوريكو ، خرجت من منزلها
معها فقط  بيجامة وهي تصرخ
لماذا لا يحبني أحد ، لماذا يحبني أي شخص
وكانت الفتاة ربما تبلغ من العمر 9 أو 10
سنوات وأنا فقط قلت لنفسي أنه لا
أحد يجب أن يعاني هذا الشاب من
هذه الدرجة من اليأس والألم لذلك هناك
يجب أن يكون شيئًا يمكننا أن نقدمه
لأشخاص كهذا يمكنهم تقديمه للأطفال
لمنحهم الأمل وهذا حقًا ما
حفز بحثي عن هذا
الشيء وتوج بكوني
مسلمًا ، وهذا ما فعلته